there is a wise old Japanese saying the
nail that sticks out gets hammered down
well down in Tokyo there's one nail that
sticks out just about as far as you can
imagine an inventor known across the
country a mad genius with a staggering
number of patents tongue sanguine
imagining hey Gavin yeah Thomas Alva
Edison know somebody up that includes a
wig for self defense meet you shiro
Nakamatsu you may notice his name is
spelled Nakamatsu he dropped the letter
you because he says an eight letter name
is easier to remember but he still wants
you to pronounce it you got a duck dr.
Nakamatsu score key inventions brought
him worldwide recognition inventions
like the P on P on booths with Springs
that put an extra bounce in your step
there's dr. Nakamatsu Surrey Breck's it
looks like a lazy boy but the doc says
the darn thing enhances brain power
then there's the gold golf putter that
paints when you strike the ball Oh would
you look at that you know you've made it
when the streets are named after you
but make no mistake dr. Nakamatsu
inventions aren't all noisy golf clubs
and bouncy shoes he claims to invented
the floppy disk that's right that floppy
disk retractable landing gear
a widely used kerosene pump and even the
digital watch
to maintain his hyper creativity dr.
Nakamatsu keeps his mind and body in
shape
that lightweight inventor Thomas Edison
said genius is 1% inspiration and 99%
perspiration is that your secret dr.
Nakamatsu yeah Ezra expiration Donna no
Sara nuestro dosel khodataeva con todas
CNO yeah
static guru matter camel toe toe toe
covering a jumble changes
Nathanael Reba tere bin Laden Patoka
Jeon abandoned temple Sunnah is say hi
Donna Donna has no creative Khanna
dynamic remedy that's my new motto me
Noah it's more Beethoven die gonna die
some actual study as Muhammad Remus sir
a demo domina by our own destiny aku not
anonymous crew a secret of the Daruma
optimism missus no not animal to holders
[Music]
mizuna Panama where most of the sands
Oona nonny
[Music]
Monica cameo has mesh mosh day
soryo motifs each element a toast huzzah
- Tesoro Memon todo y koto Atomos
cinnamon oh great enrico biomat ago toe
wisdom on tonight Oh sigh so Tina's Oh
Madonna no day sinico hats researcher
dr. Cotterill chili o'connor Hodgman
horse texture is your new machine gun
cried master attack schewe tending
vanishes master dr. Nakamatsu saw the
cancer as an opportunity it was his
greatest challenge to invent his way out
of an impossible corner he developed his
own personal cancer treatment
this includes a meticulously documented
diet and a new invention to fight the
cancer he calls the Gangan robe
the doctors gave him one year to live
that was five years ago
[Music]
but actua quue sudesna t stay low gentle
motor Mason what actua rocket so stay
services
- Tina Choi Hyun Joo sang not a tequila
so dos uno Cienega not to sin puñado de
Mishima's NK demo ad actua cinema dejas
meiosis guru desho natte Inanna attack
Shiva Street Oh No Sergio Matamata tight
a tomar el paradis selenium they attack
us yes
[Music]